[Music]
hi
only et was behind the scenes for the
latest taping of Caitlyn Bristow's
podcast one show off the vine with
special guests Heidi Montag and Spencer
Pratt how did you become fans of Caitlyn
and friends with Caitlyn her snapchat
she's one of the best snapchatters out
there and we love Canadians obviously
and a Bachelor yeah what do we reveal on
the podcast today oh oh that uh no
Pink's allowed in our son's baby room
that was like I love the color pink so
that kind of threw me off whoa wait for
a girl for that are you already thinking
about baby number two I am you know what
it took me a while years to convince
Spencer to have baby number one so I'm
just trying to put it in there you know
it's not anytime soon but you got to
work on these things always what I've
learned how do you feel about that I'm
learning I'm learning this is new no
it's not new it's not new so massage
yeah yes we talked all things baby with
the couple after the podcast Heidi and
Spencers first child a boy is due this
fall do we feel prepared for baby are we
ready
I'm not ready we just we've been moving
so much and I haven't had a chance to
even do the nursery and I have no idea
what I need and the baby registry and a
baby shower so it definitely in the next
few months to prepare do you feel
prepared oh no definitely I'm in way
over my head here and I'm glad hiding
pretending that she's not what kind of
parents do we think we're gonna be do we
even know yet we're gonna be very
letting parents I'm very strict to I
really want to have a lot of boundaries
with our kids and yeah it'll be great
Spencer
well you are kind of convinced Kaitlyn
that maybe it's time for her and Shawn
to have a baby today we definitely think
her and Shawn B should have a baby
ASAP yeah they have to be around the
same age as our first child we have to
play
we need to visit them in Nashville and
Kristin Cavallari so she needs to step
it up oh great if you get it option yeah
that was the hard Charmaine marriage
boot camp yeah I'm like wait they asked
for this one you're also convincing her
to do more reality TV do you guys want
to do more reality TV as a family I
think that'd be fun and interesting I
think that we're about to be in the next
chapter of our lives and we don't really
know where that's gonna be and would be
very entertaining to see that scary
scary sounds sounds scary
[Music]
you